[Music]
the design of this little trees car
freshener goes way back to 1952
Watertown and an unhappy milkman was
complaining to one of his customers
found the bad smell of spoiled milk
lucky for him he was talking to Julius
salmon a Jewish chemist who'd fled from
Nazi Germany and spent time living in
the forests of Canada studying the aroma
of Alpine trees after his chance
encounter with the milkman salmon
started to create paper soaked in
natural pine oil a string was also
attached to stop people getting the
perfume all over their hands the
freshener was originally in the shape of
a buxom pin-up girl but salmon changed
his design to the pine trees we know
today this allowed the cellophane
wrapper to be rolled down slowly so the
fragrance would last that little bit
longer as the automotive industry took
off so did little tree filling the air
with classics like black ice royal pine
vanilla aroma and of course a new car
scent fragrant and affordable this is
the design that brings you the heady
aroma of a Canadian woodland whether
you're in a milk cart
or taxicab
[Music]
you